[Music]
so daniel leck is the co-founder and ceo
of spotify the music streaming giant
today it's worth over 50 billion dollars
on the public markets and not only that
daniel eck was our first cover subject
of the inaugural under 30 issue a decade
ago
we put him on the list when spotify had
just launched the united states
they had a net worth of around 2 billion
as a company fast forward today daniel
ack has not only saved the music
industry he's created a 50 billion
dollar company and he himself is worth
more than four billion dollars so we
thought
what a perfect person to go full circle
a decade later and put ek back on the
cover of the under 30 issue
when you meet him he is soft-spoken and
has this zen-like calm to him he's very
quiet and understated but that hides an
absolute relentless drive to get things
done and to build spotify what's really
interesting about daniel is he came into
his music business as a young outsider
you know music is dominated by new york
and hollywood and london and all these
high-powered managers and artists and
incomes daniel eck
from stockholm sweden of all places
young very understated and he was able
to do what no one else could do and that
was combined tech and combined
experience but also combined the
business and record contracts to get
everyone to agree to give him all these
songs and then monetize it and he keeps
that drive going over and over again
this is what ek had to say we sat down
with him in 2012. i got handed a guitar
when i was like
four and i get handed a computer when i
was five so it was always like my
destiny i think to do something with
music and technology and do it in some
shape of work we also had napster pretty
early on in sweden and we had ubiquitous
broadband and what that meant was that
people were consuming so much music so
early on like 1999 and napster changed
pretty much the whole world for me i
mean it's the internet service that
changed my life the most i would say but
the unfortunate part was obviously they
didn't pay artists so really at that
point when naps were shut down i started
thinking about how can you make it
better and
only you know many years after
in 2006 was the time when i felt now i
know the answer and i got back to it and
i really went to try to convince the
record label
to say hey
here's a more convenient and better way
to piracy and by doing that you're going
to grow the music industry again 20
years ago cds reigned supreme if you
wanted music especially if you were
younger you'd have to save up your money
maybe ask your parents or someone to
drive you to the tower records or record
store buy that cd and then you know
maybe you'd you know tape things on the
radio but you had to own these these
discs
then napster came around in the early
2000s and suddenly everyone's computer
became a universal jukebox because of
file sharing you could grab any song you
wanted and suddenly you had this entire
infinite jukebox at the tip of your
fingers record labels and the music
industry which were so tied to ownership
so tied to cds were going in an absolute
plunge and everyone thought it will
never come back because this piracy is
so hard to stop and it's so easy so
daniel eck and his team at spotify said
can we build something that had the ease
of napster
the unlimited music of napster but in a
way that a has a better user interface
than piracy no viruses and more
importantly it would actually bring
money back to the artists and that was
the special sauce like literally i was
in their office every week for three
years
just
hammering them and like every argument
that they had i was trying to find a
counter argument and i adapted my
strategy and came back so persistence is
like the key but i would also say
what i did early on probably smartest
decision i've ever done was we built the
product that we knew
would change consumers lives so we built
it and we got it in the hands of the
record label guys and you know after a
while once you've started playing around
with spotify you realize okay holy
this is different and this is the future
the recording industry in 2011 was just
over 14 billion total revenue global and
all recorded music
and streaming was tiny bit of that
revenue it was only about 600 million
dollars of sales making up about 4 of
the global hull
fast forward to today that number has
jumped 40
last year the global recording industry
made just under 22 billion dollars and
streaming made up 62 percent of that
entire revenue so it's gone in a decade
from four percent
to 62 and it didn't cannibalize in fact
it grew that pie that much bigger
daniel went from
a young shy 28 year old startup founder
to now as ceo of a publicly traded
company
he's married now has two girls it's been
a big 10 years
you